[Music]
one of the things that's been really
interesting about the tech companies of
the last you know 15 to 20 years is that
they've not only been innovating in
terms of their technology but also in
terms of their business models and
actually most of the successful tech
companies are some sort of platform
company their marketplaces like Amazon
matching buyers and sellers of products
or eBay they have advertising market
places like Google
all of these are platform companies and
so not only do they have to do technical
innovation but they also have to do
business and economic innovation there's
so many questions that come up in
operating these businesses as well as in
thinking about their strategy but just
have not been addressed before you can't
just you know call a consulting company
and say like what's the best practice
like I would for a factory if you're
operating a marketplace like an air B&B
you have buyers consumers who want to
rent and you have sellers who are the
the owners of the homes the marketplace
has to really think about both sides of
the market on the sell side of the
market the home owners have to keep
their calendars current how annoying is
it to try to book a vacation home and
then have your reservation cancelled
because in a person says oops sorry my
calendar was wrong or wasn't available
so it's really important that the
suppliers in these marketplaces provide
a high-quality service keep their
calendars current answer questions
quickly provide good customer service
and good quality and they only do that
if they have the incentives to do so and
those incentives in turn are created by
the marketplace so there's a real
marketplace management challenge that's
new to these these tech marketplaces and
then the bigger platforms have strategic
considerations that are quite profound
especially because a lot of these
markets tend to be pretty concentrated
when you when you have a platform market
more buyers more sellers more sellers
more buyers more users more apps more
apps more users you don't have a lot of
opportunities to make mistakes and come
back later Microsoft was a little bit
late to the mobile phone market even
though they understood operating systems
been
than Google they missed the boat and so
they really have to get the strategy
right and understand all of the issues
about industry structure so we've seen
things like you know Google they created
a browser people like Google they're our
search engine how can they make a
browser but if you understand the
platform economics you understand why it
was really important for Google to have
a browser because the browser chooses
the default search engine and if people
are using your browser then the default
search engine will be your search engine
and that can be a really important
strategic advantage
so faced with all those those very
non-standard and quite challenging
problems most of the leading tech firms
have brought in not just sort of you
know macroeconomists who do forecasting
which is the traditional chief economist
type of role but they brought in micro
economists who think a lot more about
these strategic questions and also about
marketplace management and and pricing
policies and things like that
the evolution of a new tech firm is that
you have to start with an idea for a
product the next part is really
engineering you need to build the
product you need to deliver the product
and you need to incremental e make it
better until you get to some sort of
scale once you get to the point that you
then need to think about earning a
profit and becoming sustainable that's
really when the economics comes in and
so a lot of times that's a stage where a
firm will start trying to bring in this
expertise and of course you hire your
business people but often these problems
are so challenging and non-standard that
just a you know a generic business
background may not be enough and so
that's also a moment where the tech
economist can come in and bring in a
sort of academic perspective on it to be
able to design new systems to design the
reputation systems to design the pricing
systems to design an auction model if an
auction model is needed and so on and
they will change the companies by
teaching the engineers and teaching the
machine learning folks who might have
built the basic algorithms how to map
the business objectives onto their
engineering even determining what are
the goals what measures should be using
what KPI is should be using in business
lingo and it turns out that some
measurements that sound intuitive turn
out not to work very well for operating
a business they might be manipulable
they might not really represent
long-term success and so getting the
right measures that really capture the
organization's goals but still can be
measured in a timely fashion is
something that requires a lot of
economics and sort of business expertise
the tech firms really need economists
who can think about strategic questions
like industry structure that requires
understanding of sort of game theory and
industrial organization turns out that
you know some industry structures make
sense and some are really not
sustainable and then there's more of the
micro economic marketplace management if
you have a market place you know like a
Airbnb or like a Yelp which is a review
platform you need to really think about
the incentives of all the people
involved and you need to manage those
incentives so there's the economic
theory around what those incentives are
and designing and sent ofor all the
participants then there's also the
measurement we need to know how strong
those incentives have to be we need to
measure what the big problems are and we
design experiments that that test the
the impact of innovations and actually
designing experiments at a market place
is really quite difficult because
there's equilibrium effects if I I can't
just change things for 1% of the
suppliers and expect that to have the
same effect as if I change it for all
suppliers it's different of you and all
of your competitors experience a change
versus if just a single supplier
experiences that change by themselves
there are concerns about antitrust and
competition policy there are concerns
about privacy and security there are
concerns about new service providers how
do we think about you know regulating
the new Brewers and the lifts and so on
what are the rules that apply to these
new business models and so for all of
those types of questions the economists
role is to both conceptualize what are
the costs and benefits of what's going
on and also again to bring data to bear
the relationship between academia and
business has really changed with the
advent of tech firms historically there
was a bit of a divide you were an
academic or you were you know part of a
firm but because there's so many new
problems coming up in tech firms that
really require sort of cutting-edge
research and original thinking firms
have started plucking a very different
type of person into the into them
including putting a lot of emphasis on
very top academics and so how Varian was
you know the first example of this a
chief economist at Google Preston McAfee
went to to Yahoo and then I went to
Microsoft at the time that I spent time
at Microsoft I really got a lot of
pushback from my colleagues there was a
sense that well I had gone to do this
and I would never come back but I
understood that a huge part of my value
came from the types of skills I was
using in academics and so I was honing
my academic skills I was improving them
they taught me machine learning you know
they taught me a be testing the science
was more advanced inside the firm than
it was outside there was nothing like
that happening in academics at the time
now some people though have decided to
stay in in the tech firm careers and I
think one reason that academics are
happy there is that their jobs are
actually just really really interesting
they're doing the same quality of work
and the same rigor and challenge that
they would get in academics except for
the impact is immediate you're just
really seeing the the consequences of
your decisions much more quickly you
have control over the environment you
can build things at the beginning it was
pretty hard to bring in young people
newly minted economists and have them be
productive but as the groups have grown
it's there's now a career path and we're
seeing better and better young people
deciding to come into these jobs and
going to these tech firms can give them
the chance to do really rigorous
thinking and be really challenged
intellectually while changing products
and also living in an interdisciplinary
environment where they can learn new
skills from computer scientists and
engineers that they wouldn't have
interacted
otherwise
I think that economists are going to be
more attentive to the all of the social
science aspect and by the way other
social scientists are also contributing
and tech firms as well the behavioral
economics can really try to bring in the
perspective of what are the mistakes
consumers might make and how can I
design user interfaces or experiences to
help consumers make better decisions I
also think that when you see in a
marketplace say that you know a little
symbol that says the seller responds
within one hour to email requests or
even you know changes we've seen in the
review systems where instead of just
asking you for five stars they ask you
you know what is what was it that was
good here and they're careful about not
showing you the other person's review
until after you've put in your review a
lot of that is about economics and
incentives and trying to make sure that
the systems and the rules are set up so
that they provide the right incentives
for people to give the give honest
information and not retaliate and so on
so I think the the influence of the of
the economists are present and a lot of
those types of examples broadly then I
think what the economists are bringing
is sort of a way of thinking a way of
thinking about measurement a way of
thinking about the mapping of business
objectives to metrics and especially a
way of thinking about incentives
[Music]